et qu'en est il du canada au delà des
mesures d'urgence déjà annoncés par
ottawa quelle ampleur va prendre le plan
de relance de l'économie est ce qu'il
nous faut un plan marshall
je vais en discuter avec alain duthoit
il est ancien ambassadeur du canada
fellow invité au cirano
il a réfléchi à cette question dans son
monsieur du toit noir
est-ce que vous pensez que ça nous prend
un plan marshall pour reconstruire le
canada peut-être en profiter pour nous
ré expliquer un peu de quoi il s'agit
oui d'abord le plan marshall c'est un
programme d aide aux entreprises et aux
pays européens à la fin de la dernière
guerre mondiale qui a été une
catastrophe humaine humanitaire est
aussi lourde en perte
l'immobilier tout ça donc il a fallu
reconstruire l'europe et le plan
marshall a été un programme de prêts de
l'ordre de 175 milliards de dollars en
dollars de 2010 pour l'europe à devenir
nous avoir l'embarras du canada
possiblement la question est difficile à
répondre à les circonstances actuelles
car nous sommes tous dans l'incertitude
dans j'irai une connaissance de nuit
connaissance de l'évolution du virus est
aussi de l'impact de ce virus
coronavirus doit avoir sur l'économie
canadienne et économie mondiale
justement monsieur du toit en raison de
toutes ces incertitudes est ce que ce
serait risqué d'investir massivement si
finalement la pandémie et finit par se
résorber dans six mois par exemple je
doute
nous doutons que la pandémie puis se
résorber dans aussi peu de temps les
pronostics les plus simples et plus
positifs optimistes parlent de 18 mois
d'août de 24 mois alors déjà on
entrevoit une période de récession très
longue certains parlent de dépression
économique de risque de dépression
économique
alors je pense qu'il serait plus prudent
pour le canada de prévoir un
investissement système massif mais du
moins très ciblé et importants dans les
infrastructures stratégiques du canada
on sait que le gouvernement fédéral y
réfléchit on a déjà dégagé plus de 200
milliards de dollars en réponse du
jean si vous voulez face à cette crise
là quelle ampleur ça pourrait prendre ce
plan marshall pour le canada écoutez il
est à l'heure actuelle les économies
canadienne d'abord les perspectives
économiques indiens sont assez
préoccupant au moment et nous pourrions
parler lation regarde les des états unis
si on regarde l'europe et je vous donne
un ordre de grandeur
loin de là nous avons déjà développe des
pensées on a des fils de 343 milliards
de dollars on a une tête qui avoisine
les 2000 et le trillion de dollars donc
cette lettre est déjà très lourd alors
je pense qu'on parle d'un ordre de
grandeur d'une centaine de milliards de
dollars mais encore une fois est très
approximatif que je vous offre à l'heure
actuelle jeu il faut garder à l'esprit
cependant qu'il ya déjà des
investissements qui sont budgétés
jusqu'en 2028 et qui pourrait être
recalibrer ou réorienter pour répondre
aux enjeux très par la pandémie etc
d'investissement déjà budgétés on parle
de 180 milliards de dollars déjà
d'inscrits dans l'élite du devant nantes
une erreur ce n'est pas négligeable
alors donc égalé d'investissement
pourrait déjà être mobilisés heureux se
réorienter en fonction des 7 et surtout
accélérer les dépenses d'investissement
l'enjeu ce pas tant la quantité de la
quantité bien sûr été aussi le times le
moment de ces investissements et peut
investir rapidement quand on parle
surtout de projets d'infrastructures
dans la plupart des cas mais ce qu'on
doit aussi tenir compte de la dimension
environnementale ya l'europe aujourd'hui
on semblait traduire des des conditions
pour cette aide financière ce soutien
face à l'économie on disait 30% des sols
doivent à aller à des projets verts est
ce qu'on pourrait faire la même chose au
canada
c'est essentiel pour moi et pour
l'ensemble des observateurs le
coronavirus lakovic 19 et un de ces
chocs 1 de cette tendance brutale qui a
deux qui nous affecte tous
et c'est le précurseur de ce qui nous
attend à un cours moyen terme avec
les changements climatiques donc oui je
dirais que les investissements
d'infrastructures qui devrait type doit
être accélérée devrait avoir une forte
dimension de rites faciliter la
transition énergétique qui était
essentielle pour l'économie pour la
société car c'est le même combat
on parle beaucoup d'investissement de
l'argent qu'on comble qu'on débloque si
vous voulez mais vous évoquez vous
évoquez aussi dans votre document un
nouveau modèle de gouvernance et
d'opérations qu'est ce que vous entendez
par là l'enjeu pour la plupart des
organisations publiques et privées que
ce soit au canada dans plusieurs pays
occidentaux
c'est que nous utilisons toujours des
modèles de gouvernance et d'opérations
qui sont très hiérarchique très
compartimenté en silo au mode silos et
qui sont peu agile
on a vu l'impact on a vu la lourdeur
administrative de notre système de santé
au canada et au québec en particulier et
ce type de modèle lourd on est re et 2 e
âge il doit être transformé absolument
parce qu'il n'ya pas que les
investissements et aussi à la capacité
d'exécution et notre capacité
d'exécution faso transforme à
l'accélération des transformations
profondes qui ont les dans notre société
que de notre économie de la seule façon
de gérer cette transformation à cette
accélération des transformations et
d'adopter des modes d'organisation des
modèles d'organisation qui sont beaucoup
plus agile beaucoup plus orienté sur la
collaboration multisectorielle
multidisciplinaire et publics et privés
cannabis internationale aussi mais c'est
notoire elle est essentielle elle est
essentielle la pandémie et les
changements climatiques
ce sont des enjeux mondiaux ce sont des
gens jeunes qui vont frapper de plein
fouet le canada mais aussi dans celle de
l'ensemble du monde entier et tout comme
la collaboration est excellente à la
lecture niveau médical pour la poursuite
de la recherche d'un d'un vaccin
elle et des enjeux climatiques et la
pandémie la pandémie qui n'est pas la
dernière pandémie baby alors cette
collaboration est essentielle
oui je remercie beaucoup pour les
explications mais c'est du toit
mais puis on va voir